there's been a big release of data this
morning let's take you through the
headline figures
38.8 percent of people at major a e's
had to wait more than four hours to be
seen the target is 5
and it's a rise of a third compared with
a year ago when 28 of people waited more
than four hours to be seen and that is
despite the number of people attending
major anes actually going down to 1.5
million that's the lowest level since
march 2021 when if you remember we were
three months into the third lockdown now
december was also a record month for
category one ambulance call outs that's
for patients with life-threatening
conditions 82
361 is the new record october 2021 was
the busiest month before that it took on
average 9 minutes and 13 seconds for an
ambulance to arrive in december which is
almost two minutes slower than last year
when the average wait time was seven
minutes and 25 seconds
there's also been a rise of 28
in the last week and the number of staff
absent from nhs acute trust in england
due to covert either through sickness or
self-isolation that equates to more than
45 000 staff
and if you want to find out how your
local nhs trust is doing you can head to
the nhs news